a local lawmaker is now looking into the
material that's based on sex and gender
for students as young as age six it's
called a gender unicorn and it's meant
to explain gender identity
slabs represent different parts of the
lgbtq plus Community hey Boyle look at
all these families
just passed a law to take children away
from their family parents do not accept
the child's chosen gender identity they
don't tell the parent is because the
parent might not affirm that and the
schools consider that abusive a law that
says since it's abusive now we're going
to send CPS after you call it gender
therapist she basically like pushed me
to change my genders I 100
[Music]
California must step up and provide
Refuge to these transgender children and
their families California is making
history as the first state in the nation
to serve as a sanctuary for transgender
Youth and their families the
self-expression closet opened on our
campus this month the goal of the
transition closet is for our students to
be able to wear the clothes that their
parents approve of come to school and
then swap out into the clothes that fit
who they truly are we do have a flag in
the class that you can Pledge Your
Allegiance to oh that one
I think to them things like being fluid
with their identities comes really
naturally
warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised
[Music]
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at LED live today we're going
to be talking about a very sensitive
topic but a very important topic and
with me I have my friend Kathy Smith
she's going to be telling us a lot of
statistics and a lot of things that are
happening in the world that may be very
shocking to you so this is your parental
advisory if you have little ones around
this is very educational stuff but maybe
you should present this to them in a way
that is a little more discreet but we're
going to be just out in the open we're
going to give you this information
because we think you guys need to know
you know we need to shine the light in
the darkness so thank you for coming on
the show and sharing your information
with us and uh you said you had a story
yeah I'd like to start with a story and
just to share a little bit my own
background on for the past 30 years I've
worked with high risk youth and in
different situations and I feel like God
has been preparing me all this time for
this so I'd like to start off with a
story this is a true story it's called
what I've learned rescuing my daughter
from her transgender fantasy and this
came from the daily signal my daughter
was an ultra feminine girl since birth
she insisted that her room be painted
pink and she refused to wear anything
but dresses until third grade she
aborted her older brother's toys and
sports choosing tea sets and Shopkins a
series of tiny collectible toys her
favorite activity was to slip into my
closet and Dawn a few sparkly clothes in
the shiniest of heels she rejected
Sports in favor of Art and sewing that
abruptly changed when she turned 12. as
her body matured into young Womanhood
she stopped begging for a bikini and
avoided any clothing that accentuated
her figure she hid her breasts under
men's extra large sweatshirts I remember
doing something similar as my body's
chain so I didn't worry at first then my
daughter immersed herself into anime and
co-splain the hobby of dressing like
Fantastical carrots characters I
supported her creative side I didn't
know that anime and cosplaying can
overwhelm a young mind I didn't know
that anime and cosplaying involve gender
bending themes that the community
crosses into pedophilic and sexual
themes I also didn't know that the older
cosplay Community groomed the younger
cohorts during that same time my
daughter went through Teen Talk a
Manitoba canada-based program that said
it provides youth with accurate
non-judgmental information on sexuality
reproductive Health body issues
substance abuse awareness mental health
issues of diversity and anti-violence
issues like bullying at our Public
School she came home with a whole new
language she and all her friends her
girlfriends discussed their labels
polyamorous lesbian pansexual none of
the five girls chose basic their term
for a straight girl now I was worried
she distanced herself from her old
friends and spent more time online I
checked her phone but I was not astute
enough to know that she had set up an
appropriate fake social media accounts
for my viewing as an older girl show
romantic interest in her I barred that
girl from our home I learned later that
she had molested my daughter
when my daughter was in the eighth grade
as a Christmas gift I took her to SAC
anime an anime convention in Sacramento
California there she met a girl three
years her senior but light years more
mature the girl mesmerized my daughter
with her edginess or magnanimous
personality the older girl went by they
after they're viewing my daughter got a
boy's haircut stopped shaving and asked
for boys underwear my daughter parented
everything about this older teen
she started making gross Tick Tock
videos her language became vulgar and
she redeciderated her room to look like
a cave she self-pierced her nose with
one of those bull Rings she broke every
family rule she was morphing into an emo
goth vampire-like creature she was
unrecognizable her personality descended
into anger and rudeness the summer
before ninth grade she announced that
she was a transgender post announcement
announcement she began to threaten
suicide she sunk into deep depression I
managed to get all of her passwords on
her social media accounts what I saw was
jaw-dropping almost everyone that she
was conversing with was a stranger
except for the sack anime friend who
sent her a self-made she entertained
video the discussions on The discus
platform involved fetish sexual
conversations kids were sending each
other erotica include including
involving
older girls were instructor younger
girls how to sell nude photos of
themselves to men for money
girls bragged about their different
mental illnesses they talked about which
drugs do what they talked about if there
were really boys not girls they
discussed Top surgery that is having
their breasts removed and Packers that
creates a bulge in one's pants to imply
the presence of a penis
my Dora's electronic devices were filled
with Tick Tock videos YouTubers talking
about how great they felt now that they
had transitioned there were messages in
which strangers told her to kick my head
in because I was a transfer for refusing
to call her by her male name
I went nuclear I took the phone and
stripped it of all the social media
YouTube Instagram Discord Reddit pin
interested Twitter I even blocked her
ability to get into the internet I
deleted all of her contacts and changed
her phone number I sat next to her while
she attended School online via Zoom I
deleted YouTube from the smart TV and
locked up all the remotes I took every
anime book from her room I threw away
all her costumes I banned any friend who
was not who was even the slightest bit
unsavory I involved the police about the
panel I printed out the lore and
informed that if anyone sent her I would
not hesitate to prosecute she hated me
like an attic hates the person
preventing their drug fix I held my
grounds despite the constant verbal
abuse after going through seven mental
health professionals I found an
out-of-state psychiatrist who was
willing to examine the causality for my
daughter's sudden trans identity I
immerse myself in reading everything on
the issue talking to other parents and
other professionals I worked unceasingly
to recreate the bond she and I used to
share after a year and a half of utter
hell my daughter is finally returning to
her authentic self a beautiful artsy
kind and loving daughter I'm not sure
what the actual ingredients for the
magic potion was for alleviating her
gender dysphoria the formula will vary
but what I did after a very brief
misstep of using a male name our family
and all the adults in my child's life
she's only her birth name and
corresponding pronouns we did not permit
social transition although we could not
control the school setting unbelievably
our local Catholic School refused to
follow our edict as I mentioned
previously we pulled the plug on the
social media and her access to anyone
other than those persons we vetted I
forced my daughter to listen to specific
podcasts on the subject while driving
her to school I printed out stories
about female trans D transitioners women
who had medical eyes but then regretted
their actions and returned to living as
a woman and I left them throughout the
house
I left all my research out in plain view
including the book irreversible damage
the transgender craze seducing our doors
by Abigail Shire gender dysphoria a
therapeutic model for working with
children adolescents and young adults by
Susan Evans at other books I followed
the advice of parents for ethical cares
broadcasts and the book desist the trans
and detox getting your child out of the
gender cult by Maria keffler I worked
hard to take back the close relationship
my daughter and I once had I bit my
tongue until it bled I took her anger
and only responded with love or walked
away when I knew I would respond poorly
I caught her in vulnerable moments and
hugged her or climbed into her bed I
stopped looking at her as though she was
the victim of a scheme or a monster I
let her know that I would never stop
fighting for her
I let her see the posters from the
protest I attended I peppered her with
questions that demonstrated theologic of
gender ideology I happened to have a
funny gender critic critical memes on my
computer when she walked into my office
most importantly I held my ground I
refused to accept her her delusion with
compassion I know that I have to
continue to be tenuous as the gender
ideology has crept into every facet of
life but for now I can breathe a sign of
relief wow that is a powerful story just
to talk about how much an impact like
your surroundings have like your the
media they're talking about the
influence some of the anime and all this
stuff like people think that this
doesn't have an impact on you it most
certainly does I can identify a lot with
that story not because I was trans or
any kind of homosexual but I was a
teenager raised in a normal Christian
home and I began to be drawn to these
things because of MTV like the
glamorizing Rebellion alcoholics you
know drinking and hooking up at the
beach and all these things and then the
rock stars and I began to wear pantyhose
skirts makeup all this stuff not
homosexual at all but just thinking like
who who can say this is made for female
this is made for male this is who I am
and I 100 believed like this was me
that's not me anymore so
for people to say like no this is who
you are this is you're born this way
this is you know this is the real you
that's not true man people go through
phases like she said in the beginning
she thought this is a phase you know
she's hiding okay maybe she was a tomboy
at one point she outgrew that but uh
it's it's beautiful to see how her mom
fought for her and won her affections
back won her trust back and and freed
her daughter from this you know and
that's what we're hoping to do with this
program is is show how Christ can free
you from all these deceptions in the
world well you know if if uh you know TV
and all this didn't impact Madison
wouldn't be spending all that money on
commercials so this this stuff
absolutely impacts our our kids and
that's why as parents we have to be
aware of
of social media and what they're being
exposed to we have to be aware if media
didn't have an impact there wouldn't be
a such thing as a cancer culture exactly
and there wouldn't be a such thing as
representation nobody would care if it's
just meaningless mind mindless
entertainment that literally has no
impact then there'd be no push for we
need a representation we're going to
cancel this we're going to do this media
is very powerful and influential I want
to talk a little bit about the LGBT
community and how it has increased over
time now I'm going to give two polls one
of them is a Gallup poll and the other
one is a Barner poll so I'll give you
the gallop first because this is a
longer poll they went back to the 1940s
and they called these people's
traditionalists and at that time in the
1940s 1.3 percent of the population
identified as LGBT by the time the baby
booters came along which is me it was
two percent uh Gen X it was 3.8 percent
Millennials 9.1 percent and gen Z is
15.9 so you can see every year it's
pretty much doubled the Barnard study
talks about the fact that the
Millennials are 30 percent LGBT and the
Gen Z is 39 and now these are the people
there that were going to be in our in
our our schools they're the people going
to be in our churches etc etc so the
LGBT community is growing what is
causing this right so the highest
percentage of this group is the Young
The Young the youth and what are they
growing up in in a world where there's
all this representation where in their
schools they're actually teaching you
about transgenderism they're you know
now they're wearing teachers are wearing
these badges with a QR code by wearing
our badge you tell everyone that you are
a safe person this also comes with a
disclaimer that indicates that if you
are not a safe person to not wear the
badge so now teachers are being cordoned
off by this particular caucus group of
who is safe and who is labeled not safe
that a student can come up there
anonymously or whatever take a picture
of it and it takes you to this
disgusting stuff about BDSM and and all
these horrible sexual acts why would any
teacher think they have the authority to
teach your children about sex and
especially elementary kids well they're
starting they're starting now with with
two-year-olds they're starting in
preschool teaching there's something
called the gender unicorn but they're
starting to teach kids like uh what the
gender you're born with and the gender
that you identified with and how it's
fluid you could be a boy one day and a
girl the next day and a lot of times
parents aren't even aware of what's
what's being taught in the schools and
it starts at very young ages and we're
also going to do some clips about what's
going on in you know in kids cartoons
and and things like that to see it's
it's it's infiltrated every part of our
society how can a parent even keep up
you know that we're in a system now
where both parents have to work so they
don't have time to do anything and you
know what they're going to have to no if
they're going to have to do something I
mean you see how the system is being set
up yes in order to like allow this to
happen well you know because there was a
time when the the husband he went he was
the breadwinner the wife she uh you know
taught the child and in home or there's
a small Schoolhouse or whatever very
involved in a parent-teacher conference
all these things but that's like
non-existent anymore well not so much I
mean there is a homeschooling community
and after what after um with covid a lot
more people are now homeschooling I'm
sorry but there's no excuse parents have
to do this they have to they have to
protect their kids God has put them over
the over their children and so they're
going to have to do some sacrificing and
my my Niche just had a baby and she's
she's staying home she's going to be a
homeschooling mother and she said no
television no social media okay so this
is something parents have to do and um
yeah so yes it's it's going to be hard
there's going to be sacrifice my sister
homeschooled all her kids she could have
went to work and her kids could have had
the newest of everything she went to
garage sales to get her kids Christmas
gifts but she did that so that she could
homeschool them and protect them from
what was going on in society so as
Christian parents we have to do this I
love garage sales yard sales all that
hey if you believe in recycling there's
a lot of waste from products that people
buy and they don't even use them so I'm
all about it
um we're gonna show a clip here from
Nickelodeon like this is what's
happening this is being targeted towards
kids like you said as young as two or I
mean Blue's Clues the age is very young
and just check this out
everybody every color on the pride flag
is a symbol in the sky so this is a drag
queen a very masculine woman here
um you know advertising this pride thing
this this thing goes on it's a long
music video All About pride month and
what all the colors represent but I
thought it was interesting that this
person said that it's a sign a sign in
the sky takes takes us right to the
Bible I mean Genesis 9 12-17 says and
God said this is the sign of the
Covenant this is God's covenant which I
make between me and you and every living
creature that is with you for Perpetual
Generations I set my rainbow in the
cloud and it shall be for a sign of the
Covenant between me and the Earth it
shall be when I bring a cloud over the
Earth that the rainbow shall be seen in
the cloud and I will remember my
Covenant which is between me and you and
every living creature of the of All
Flesh the waters shall never again
become a flood to destroy all flesh the
rainbow shall be in the cloud and I will
look on it to remember the Everlasting
Covenant between God and every living
creature of All Flesh that is in the
Earth and God said to Noah this is the
sign of the Covenant which I have
established between me and All Flesh
that is in the Earth
so God made this beautiful promise to
Noah to never destroy the Earth why did
he have to destroy the Earth because it
was a literally Noah and his family
eight people that were saved were
witnessing to a corrupt world for 120
years and nobody else got on that ark
Noah looked like a crazy person in a
world that believed a certain worldview
and has said that their hearts were only
evil continually
and you look around and when I grew up
I'm only 39 when I grew up
it seemed like the majority of people
around me as a kid at least said they
were Christian whether they lived it or
whatever they believed yeah I believe in
God I believe in Jesus I'm going to
heaven one day that's at least what they
confessed but now it's like if you say
you're a Christian you're labeled as
some bigot I mean that's the that's how
rapidly this has happened within a mere
25 years or so and
when we see that this community has like
hijacked the sign in the sky and
um is completely using it for Pride
which was the fall of Lucifer literally
the beginning of all this a sin
originated with this sin Pride
it's amazing but and yeah I want to also
speak to Okay so what what causes
homosexuality I mean was it who's the
singer who says Born This Way Lady Gaga
okay let me tell you right now nobody is
born gay nobody is born trans okay
um there are some studies we're going to
talk about for one thing it's
interesting in the homosexual Community
when I went to when I was in school to
get my masters of mental health you know
they were looking like crazy for the gay
gene okay they couldn't they couldn't
find it all right but what's interesting
in trans they completely throw out
genetics you can't have it both ways you
can't be talking about well you know
there's biology here but then when it
comes to Transit there's no biology
there was a study done by the Human
Rights Campaign sexual assault and the
LGBT community it mentions a number of
studies and it talks about the high
rates of sexual assault most of it or
much of it has occurred in childhood
um they talk about one of the things
that they say okay for the trans trans
people and the by bisexual Woman face
most alarming rates of sexual violence
among both of these populations sexual
violence begins early and often during
childhood they also mentioned that 48
percent of bisexual women their first
rape is between the ages of 11 and 17.
think about it if you heard you're a
trans or a bi I mean um and you've been
sexually molested as a child are you
going to feel comfortable in your body
you know so this is again a factor it's
not the only Factor there was another
study done by Fenway Health in 2015. it
was a survey by the national Center of
transgender equality and it was
interesting this one that said 47
percent of those who identify as
transgender were sexually assaulted at
some time in their life okay and it was
236 page report and I was going through
it and they were asking a lot of
questions like one of the questions was
were you assaulted by your you know your
significant other well you assaulted in
jail were you assaulted in uh some some
type of of Center or something like that
they asked all these different
categories where you handicapped in all
this the one thing that didn't ask one
did it start you see because I truly
believe if there was this information
gets out there that a lot of those
people who identify as LGBT had some
type of trauma in their background
especially a child sexual abuse that
they could 47 that is a huge significant
factor oh and these are just some of the
studies
um yeah I can I can only imagine if you
were especially like a female that was
assaulted by a male you're not going to
trust the male so you would gravitate
towards a female you know exactly and if
you're a transgender what's what's
interesting too how that affects the
team what's interesting with the males
when they get molested I hate to say but
it's almost Vogue for a female the metoo
movement men do not like to to talk
about this and what's interesting when I
was in school there was a gentleman
there who used to be a Pentecostal
pastor and he left his family to become
gay and I had mentioned about the sexual
molestation he denied it and he
introduced me to his family and his
sister came over to me and she told me
something she said when he was six years
old his 13 year old cousin molested him
there was a what is it called seduction
okay so what happens and this is
happening a lot now as I said don't
leave your kids along with any mail
especially teenagers but any male uh
what happens is they seduce they seduce
so a man might think you know I wasn't
molested but the fact of the matter is
if there was someone who's much older
than you and they're touching you
sexually you were molested
um so I hear it's when you think of rape
you think of this forceful broke into
the window but oftentimes it is it's uh
like I I know somebody personally
actually who's
found out that her husband had been
raping her daughter from another
marriage and she said it wasn't what you
would think it wasn't like he forced
himself on her it was over time
complimenting her flirting with her it's
this romantic thing where it's it's
grooming yep it's grooming exactly yeah
that's exactly what it is so so a lot of
times you know kids I've spoken to a
young adults who told me they were
same-sex attracted and I would ask about
their childhood and they would you know
I'd say you know well did anybody ever
touch you inappropriately yeah and and
again it's a seduction type of thing and
you know what's so sad they blame
themselves even as adults because it
felt good that's how our bodies are so
when adult does this to you and somebody
it's usually somebody 90 of the time
it's someone you know and trust and love
and when they do this to you you're
blaming yourself and it is a definite
factor in those who are same-sex
attracted now I'm not saying everyone
who's gay has been molested or everyone
who's been molested has become gay but
it is a significant factor right we're
all sinful creatures I wasn't raised I
wasn't in an alcoholic home but became
an alcoholic sometimes you just try
something and you like it but these are
these statistics mean something I mean
this yeah these these studies these
studies mean something I'll just mention
another one this was a recent study 2022
by Vanderbilt University a study finds
LG this they didn't use the transgender
that's lgbq report negative High rates
of Ace now let me explain what Ace is
Ace is adverse childhood experiences so
let's say things like coming from a home
of divorce a broken home uh coming A
Home of domestic domestic violence or
substance abuse and I'm going to give
you some statistics when they compared
they compared the the LGBT again not t
Community to heterosexuals what they
found was as far as child sexual abuse
within the gay community it was 30
percent heterosexually 13 emotional
abuse this just kills my heart emotional
abuse is 57 uh within the heterosexual
it's 33 physical abuse 40 percent 24 in
the heterosexual and then household
member who has mental illness 40 and
within the heterosexual except 17
percent so these are just some of the
statistics and the fact that the LGBT
community we've all been broken in some
way all of us have Brokenness in our
lives okay uh they've done the a studies
and they found out so many kids have
been raised with some type of trauma or
abuse but the LGBT community has a lot
more yeah I'm just thinking about back
to that story that you read at the
beginning where the woman said that she
was reading that they were almost like
glamorizing their mental disorders and
stuff mental disorder is on the rise uh
lgbtq is on the rise what is causing all
this confusion in the world and I don't
want to put all the blame on the media
but it's like you almost want to just
destroy the get rid of the TVs and just
see how the world transforms get rid of
the education system they did a study it
was probably from 2000 2018 they look at
the suicide rates right now the number
two rate of killing of of killing young
people 10 to 24 is suicide so from 2000
to 2018 okay so from 2000 to 2007 what
they found it was stable in 2007 it shot
up I think it was 57.4 percent I'm doing
this off my head what happened in 2007
what was invented smartphone the iPhone
okay and that's that's a whole other
talk so so what's interesting about the
iPhone is they had other smartphones
before that but it cost a lot of money
to connect to the Internet so the
average kid couldn't couldn't look at it
with the inch with the iPhone what
happened is they could now just like a
computer could view everything anywhere
so yeah as soon as the iPhone came out
the suicide rate and we'll talk later on
another talk we'll talk about the
bullying and every everything so I truly
believe social media is having a great
impact in the spread of the LGBT
ideology as well as the suicide rate
amongst our young people right and I'm
not buying into all the all the
diagnosis I think are you know some
people are just really they're grieving
they're going through normal things that
teenagers go through and they're like
nope you know what you need this med and
that Med has a side effect of this
Suicidal Thoughts I mean literally
you're taking medication on TV it says
Suicidal Thoughts call your doctor if
you're depression worsens or if you have
unusual changes in Behavior or thoughts
of suicide some people have had changes
in Behavior hostility agitation
depressed mood and suicidal thoughts or
actions while taking or after stopping
Chantix tell your doctor right away if
your depression worsens or you have
unusual changes in mood Behavior or
thoughts of suicide wait a minute what
is in a medication that's literally
telling you to kill yourself it just
really makes you think of demonic
possession you know I wonder what is the
connection here well even the hormones
we'll get into that in a little bit the
hormone is that they're giving one of
the some of the side effects are
depression anxiety and all this stuff
this is supposed to be curing this yes
but I wanted to mention when we talk
about again uh the homosexual about the
cause okay
human behavior is very complex Aid never
leads to B it's usually a times the
third power and divided by 24 times this
in other words there's so many factors
that factor into any type of human
behavior now what they're trying to say
is that homosexuality is immutable which
means that okay you were born with blue
eyes okay you can't change that of
course we put contacts in but but your
eyes are still going to remain blue so
what they're trying to say is it's
immutable that you can change and that's
not true and I'm going to mention an
interesting study okay Lisa Diamond she
is a lesbian and she's a researcher and
she did a long-term study and what she
found she started with young people
through adulthood and what she found is
what they call sexual fluidity people
can and do change their sexual
orientation and there is a Ministry
called Firestone Ministry and they did a
25-year survey and what they found was
that they had about a 70 percent rate of
what they call success in other words
someone who was gay found themselves
attracted to the opposite sex versus
that they found their homosexual
tendencies to be decreasing and he and
the gentleman who runs this ministry
said that that's about average when you
talk about any type of behavior that you
want to change seventy percent so so
things can change epigenetics okay what
epigenetics what they found and the
Bible says we're fearfully and wonderful
wonderfully made okay
our Behavior and our environment ex what
they do is they express they affect our
gene expression it affects our DNA so
what happens is you know the things in
our environment and our own behavior Can
it can express that so there's something
also called neuroplasticity and what
neuroplasticity means is your brain
changes according to behavior so they
did a study back in the 90s about
homosexual brains it was a very small
study it was actually debunked but
people still use it and they took it I
think it was like six men who were gay
and they looked at their brains and they
found a very small section that there
was there was difference but they were
also HIV positive
um so they're trying to say okay and
they're looking now at transgenders
braids and saying haha we want to find
something that says that they're
different the thing with epigenetics and
neuroplasticity is our Behavior will
affect our brain and I decided to do a
little research and I researched concert
pianist and when they compared when they
did brain studies of concert penis
versus those who weren't there was a
difference so yes epigenetics and
neuroplasticity can affect Behavior so
if you're practicing something and
especially now the kids are all into
doing everything sexually man woman
everything they're just doing everything
so the more you practice a behavior it
becomes natural to you yeah there's been
research that shows that pornography
literally changes the way a brain looks
it looks like a cocaine addict when you
look at the brain of a sober person who
is a porn addict there's a literally
that says it looks different and so yeah
so they're looking at the brain saying
ah we see what's different in them but
that is something that's been changed
because of their behavior if they looked
at the same brain when they were young
they wouldn't have seen that so they're
trying to take what is has been caused
in saying that that's like the root and
really it's not yes many times like I
said there's so many factors that factor
into anything whether it's same-sex
attraction transgender Eating Disorders
no matter what it is there's many many
different factors and again the more you
do something
um I I suffer from an eating disorder
okay because of related to trauma in the
in my past and it became very natural to
me but again with the neuroplasticity
what God showed me one day when I was
walking through the woods because I was
like God you know why am I still doing
this and he showed me there was two
paths one that was very well worn and
that's your default path and then there
was one that just started where people
just started walking when we default due
to stress or whatever it is you know we
default to this Behavior that's not a
good behavior we're deepening the neural
Pathways and it becomes natural for us
but with the power of the Holy Spirit he
helps us to take that New Path and and
the Bible says a righteous man falls
seven times so you may go back to that
you may be gay and you're like I want to
stop this Behavior you may go back or
your alcoholic or drugs or whatever it
is but if you continue with the help of
the Holy Spirit on this new path what
happens to a path when you don't use it
that starts to grow up yeah it grows up
and it goes away and then you start the
New Path and I can say for myself having
an eating disorder which I was told by
in in school that was like almost
impossible to overcome through the power
of the Holy Spirit and counseling we got
to the trauma we got to what happened
and through that I was able to overcome
that praise the Lord yeah to the root
yes exactly you know the behavior is the
fruit you got to get it the root yeah
and so so often with the whole
pharmaceutical industry is it's about
masking the problem oh you're depressed
well here's a pill to make you happy
well why are you depressed let's talk
about it let's get to the root of that
thing you know uh and then the thing
they mask it with has all the side
effects the addictions all these things
and it's a big it's a big terrible cycle
you mentioned you know we're talking
about
the atmosphere and all that and and I
wanted to show another clip because
this is this is not going away this is
getting more and more pervasive about
the younger audience so there is a clip
from Blue's Clues there's two clips I
want to show those right now and just
this is what uh children are being
raised on if their parents are not
guarding what they're watching it's an
email from our friend
no matter who they love
hey blue look at all these families hi
families this family has two mummies
they love each other so proudly and they
all go marching in this family has two
daddies they love each other so proudly
and they all go marching if these Papas
are non-binary they love each other so
proudly and they all go marching in
trans members of this family all love
each other so proudly and they all go
marching in Ace buying pan grown-ups you
see can love each other so proudly and
they all Go Marching In Love Is Love is
love you see and everyone should love
proudly and we'll all go marching it's
amazing that this I mean if this would
have been shown in the 80s or the 90s
like people would have been like what is
this get this off of our screens we have
children you're teaching them you're
supposed to teach them ABCs one two
threes not that you're pansexual like
I'm attract I'm sexually attracted to
everything and anything you know what
why are we teaching our children about
sex at all is the big mystery and it
this would be considered pedophilia or
grooming like you said exactly and um
yes and our children are being inundated
with I mean Marvel Comics came out with
I think Dr Michael Brown said there's 65
65 gay uh superheroes or and villains
um it was a joker recently became
pregnant or something but um yeah so so
our kids are being inundated with this
and that's why as parents we have to be
aware and we have to guard and we have
to protect them because that's our job
now you know you think about it like why
does God say no I mean like they just
said this is all love is love right I
want to read some statistics as far as
health goes this is the uh Centers for
Disease Control men who have sex with
men account for 83 percent of primary
that's new and secondary syphilis it the
rate is 248 times that of of other men
of heterosexual men gonorrhea they're 42
times higher than a heterosexual men and
the gonorrhea is it can get in the penis
and in the road and in the rectum okay
they did the 2020 statistics for HIV and
it was about 10 or 11 times higher than
heterosexuals okay and then there was a
magazine it's called lavender magazine
this came out in July of 2022 and they
said 20 years ago anal cancer rates were
extremely low but in the last five years
with men who have sex with men the rates
have increased 1800 percent depending on
the studies so I mean the lifestyle and
not just physically but also emotionally
and some of the mental health problems
that go along with it it's very harmful
and God is a loving father and maybe
there's some people out there who have
not grown up with a loving father but
God is a loving father and a loving
father's job is to protect their child
and provide so God when he says no to
anything and hetero said God says no to
heterosexual sex before marriage as well
because back in the day
um when in my mother's day there was
only two sexually transmitted diseases
uh it was gonorrhea and syphilis now
we've got over 30. okay and so so even
heterosexual outside of marriage God God
says no to why because he wants to
protect us he loves us he has what's
best for us so that's this is why God
wants us to have life and life more
abundantly and we when you have sex
outside marriage you're talking about
unwanted pregnancies which is going to
lead to one or two things either
abortion or a child raised in a broken
home and a child raised in a broken home
is more likely to go down a wrong path
of drugs uh sexual promiscuity and you
just restart this whole cycle see Satan
hates marriage because it's a covenant
that God created and it's
the child needs both parties and he's a
mother and the father and so like we see
a divorce going like crazy we see the uh
STDs going like crazy and like you just
said the the anal cancer was going up
1800 and in the in them in the uh the
the gay male male yes because the the
percentage of the homosexual round is
going up yeah well so the numbers are
rising together what does it say there's
a direct link and God is wanting to
protect us from these
terrible things in our life that is
going to cause death you know yes and
destruction when you mentioned about
children being raised without fathers um
there's an organization called I think
it's Darkness to light and if I'm
remembering correctly they said that
children who were raised without fathers
are 20 times more likely to be molested
could be the mother's boyfriend you know
or something like that they're 20 times
more likely to be you know as I said the
job of the father is to protect yeah or
like you said it could be the stepfather
or that
young man is trying to find a father
figure so he's around the wrong people
you know the groomers yeah oh that's
like I said that's that's a whole nother
thing that you know maybe we'll get into
another time I wanted to mention another
study uh this was again about the trans
what they say with the Trans they'll
tell a parent do you want
a dead daughter or an alive son so in
other words you need to transition this
kid because they're gonna they're gonna
commit suicide so what they're looking
at is these short-term studies because
don't forget in the United States this
isn't this is pretty much new I think it
started going up in 2010 again with the
smartphone and the access to the
internet okay and it's in Europe and
stuff like that it's just been going Sky
High so uh so in the United States
there's these short-term studies and
it's almost like when you get married
you know the first two years are good
and then then all the work starts the
honeymoon phase so yeah someone
Transitions and who's the one that jazz
I think her name is it's actually a guy
who transitioned Jazz and after the
transition put on a hundred pounds and
is still has these mental health issues
it didn't it didn't solve the problem
well there was a study that was done in
Sweden and it's called it was 2011 very
important uh and Sweden's very gay
affirming by the way because what they
try to say with the homosexuals why they
have all these problems is because it's
it's not a gay affirming Society well
there it is in Sweden and this was a
what they call a cohort study cohort
means long term it was done over 30
years that they followed these people
okay what they found with those it's
called long-term follow-up of
transsexual persons undergoing sex
reassignment surgery this is what they
found that they had 19 times the suicide
rate that committed suicide okay 19
times when compared to the general
population five times the suicide
attempts three times as far as comparing
to the general population with inpatient
psychiatric uh being into the hospital
and they also had an increase in what
they call psychiatric morbidity and what
this means is mental health problems all
right so they're trying to say again
they're trying to say that well you know
it's because they're not accepted well
they were very accepted in Sweden but
yet you've got all these these different
problems
um so yeah the it all depends on who
you're asking you know and that that's a
good segue to this next clip because
this is what the the medical world they
have a lot to gain from this right
although financially heck yeah so yeah
you found on on Twitter Matt Walsh which
he did a documentary called uh what is a
woman and he found that if Vanderbilt
opened its trans clinic in 2018 during a
lecture the same year Dr Shane Taylor
explained how she convinced Nashville
Nashville so this is in the Bible Belt
to get into the gender transition game
she emphasized that it's a big money
make especially because the surgeries
require a lot of follow-ups listen this
is straight from the horse's mouth
starting in you name my first Tony
sanity unit and right to be Affordable
Care Act insurance cover carriers are
mandated to cover medical incentives for
transphobes and some of them are being
meant to the financial votes and punt in
August of Plenty and for October of 2016
sorry a couple years ago went down some
costs but how much money do you think
increase it would bring in and this is
the only including top survey that
doesn't including any bottom surgery and
it's a lot that might be surgery made a
lot of money and so females that may not
test reconstruction then bring in forty
thousand dollars uh the patient just on
a routine watermelon treatment only
saying a few times a year then bring in
several thousand dollars so far in a lot
of visits and lab that actually makes
money for the hospital
now these are not from the internet
um but the experiment the Philadelphia
cyber transgender surgery which has a
bevel on a surgery for patient by
quantitative idea how much and spine
surgeries are making and this is I think
this has to be an underestimate uh this
is for vaginoplasty
they're saying they're floating roughly
around twenty thousand dollars or about
in the Pasty but that doesn't include
your hospital staying it doesn't include
your post-op business but doesn't that
include
um your anesthesia alarm so I would
think that this has to be a froze
underestimate I think that's just like
the so dance that piece of it which
anything because I don't know Hospital
knows an upflake I'm 10 out of this
uh and then the female to male boxing
surgeries these are huge my neighbors
again this has to be an underestimate if
they're voting around twenty thousand
dollars for a baloplastied there's three
different things I'd rather than said it
could be up to a hundred thousand
dollars
um Dr lanker who's our Southern Man said
that there's a tired clinics where the
entire Clinic is supported just by their
valoplasties and that is like a fraction
of the surgeries that they're doing
these surgeries are labor intensive
they're firing a lot of follow-ups they
require a lot of for our time and then
it might they make mine for us well I
mean this is from Dr Shane Taylor's
mouth she is in favor of transitioning I
almost thought this was a statistic or I
thought this was somebody opposed to it
because it sounded like yeah this makes
a lot of money
but this is somebody trying to sell
Nashville on doing this because it makes
a lot of money they don't care about the
people they don't care about the suicide
rates they care about the money that's
coming in she talked about a hundred
thousand dollars that's more than half
of my house costs
I mean this is insanity yeah and that's
just for one surgery so think about the
surgeries that you're doing and I don't
know if you're going to show us a
picture of the girl that had the top
surgery but when you see it it's just it
just it tears me apart and I can't
believe I'm a nurse and I just cannot
believe that the medical profession is
doing this to children I I just it just
blows me away yeah I mean children who
at some point in their life felt like
they were a dog you know it's like you
cannot let a child figure out what
gender they are you know
and when you're 18 I mean I don't even
agree with it at that point but at least
you're making a decision on your own
when you have a fully developed brain
but these are people who are profiting
off of children and and the laws are
being created you're going to go into
that where the laws are being created
where the children make the rules the
parents can't even have a say so anymore
like the government the state owns your
children at this point yes because
that's a lot of money yeah you would
mention about the brain development you
know what was interesting um I went to
McDonald's the other day and I ordered
for you know I asked for a cup of coffee
and then the person she said you have to
come inside and I was in the
drive-through and I was like yeah I'm in
a rush here and they said well the
person is only 15 and she's not allowed
to serve hot coffee yeah not allowed to
certified coffee okay I go to the YMCA
right here and uh there is there's a hot
tub there and it says no one under the
age of 16 is allowed in that hot tub wow
but yet you're allowing kids as young as
10 and even younger to to take puberty
blockers the brain does not develop
fully until until a person is 20 25
years old that's when the Judgment part
comes in that's why your insurance rates
will drop when you're 25. okay so the
brain doesn't fully develop until until
that point but yet we're allowing
children who have a history of trauma
most of them uh to make these decisions
about whether or not they're a boy or a
girl and again there's a lot of pressure
there was this is really important there
were studies that show when a child is
socially transitioned okay socially
transitioned meaning the child goes to
school a lot of times the parent aren't
even aware of this they have what they
call gender closets okay so a child can
come in dress as a boy he can go into
the closet he can put on a dress and and
makeup and things like that and when he
goes to school
um the the teachers have to address the
the boy as a girl and whatever their
pronouns are so they're being socially
Transitions and what happened is this
particular study all this behind their
parents yes
the goal of the transition closet is for
our students to be able to wear the
clothes that their parents approve of
come to school and then swap out into
the clothes that fit who they truly are
and I use the idea that this is like
Superman changing in a film in many
schools yes it's behind the parents
remember when I went to school girls
would uh leave the house wearing a lot
more clothing than when they you know
get out of their parents site and they
have a you know more provocative
clothing on but now it's like I'm a
woman outside my parents home
wow and so what happens is when they're
socially transitioned this is one study
was a five-year study done in Pediatrics
they are 97.5 uh times or 97.5 percent
will go on to medically transition okay
so socially transition if you think
about this is a kid this is a kid and
you have the teacher saying okay
confirming that they're a boy when
they're a girl you have the school
psychologist confirming this and the
medical and and so and their friends are
all confirming this because it's cool to
to be this okay and so this kid's
believing it so they're going to go on
to the puberty blockers okay now 10
studies done in 2016 there was an
analysis and what they found is that
85.2 percent of children with gender
dysphoria and they are not socially
transitions those feelings will be
remitted they will stop or aren't or
after puberty yeah makes sense so I if
we're Transit socially transitioning
these kids we're heading them right down
to a medical transitioning what's
interesting is also I mean I don't know
when this all started it'd be
interesting to look into but when do
they start putting hormones in meats and
stuff you know the estrogen pumping up
the chicken so the breast would be big
and and we're in a world where people
don't know what gender they are anymore
okay so the programming and then
whatever's in the food and they talked
about uh bottled water BPA has estrogen
mimickers in it the chemicals and the
the spraying the crops with has atrazine
in it which was causing the Frog's
gender to change so wow there are a lot
of things going on but I think a lot of
it has to do with you know the The
Grooming the social engineering that's
happening yes and and again it would be
interesting like you said to find out
studies to see to see how you know
what's going on in everything you know
like I said there's a lot of
psychological stuff going on and there's
physical stuff the the hormones and the
beauty blockers first of all they're not
FDA approved in other words they're not
approved for what they're using them for
okay these are supposed to be used for
cancer you want to give your kid a
cancer medication they're supposed to be
used for cancer and what's called
precocious puberty in other words your
five-year-old starts to develop breasts
okay or you know if it's a male or
something yeah
um you want to give this to stop it it's
a very it's a very short-term thing so
I'm just going to mention oh and it's
another thing I'm a registered nurse now
usually when you go to get a medication
the doctor will give you the pharmacist
will have this little list of you know
side effects if you really want to know
the side effects of a medication go
inside and pull out that little thing
that you can barely read and there it
will list all the side effects okay I'm
going to give you just some of the side
effects I can't put all of them in there
because this show will go too much this
is for the puberty blockers this one's
the puberty blockers then we're going to
go into the hormones okay okay so we'll
start the PV blockers and there's
several of them okay
a high risk of Osteo or increased risk
of osteoporosis it affects the brain
developments because again those
hormones that are supposed to happen
around puberty affect our brain so not
having those hormones or having the
opposite hormones are going to affect
the brain development high blood
pressure it prevents the gonadal tissues
from developing and what that means is
that let's say sperm or eggs so there's
a chance of sterility and we don't have
the long-term studies to show whether or
not this is reversible we don't have
those also it could affect a person's
ability to have an orgasm because if you
don't have that tissue there and there
was that one doctor who spoke to this
who used to transition and he says I
will not do it anymore because it
affects their ability to have intimacy
they can never they can never have
sexual intimacy with somebody you know
okay liver damage mood disorders isn't
this what this is supposed to stop right
irritability insomnia heart attack
stroke anxiety depression again claims
of reversibility are based on the FDA
use in precocious puberty no studies we
do not know what occurs if we start
giving these puberty blockers at like
age eight and maybe stop them at 16 or
18. we don't we don't know yet I don't
know if it's like reversible we don't
know if it's reversible so what happens
is that um kids can become sterile and
what kid really can understand the con
you know the thing of having children
when they're young eight years old 10
years old even 16 years old they can't
even really understand that
um and they then again studies show that
those who social transition will go on
to puberty blockers and that
dramatically increases the gender
dysphoria persistence in the child okay
testosterone we've all heard the stories
of the um the uh athletes who take it
yeah okay rage aggression mood changes
blood clots embolism heart attack stroke
death bleeding irregular heartbeat
visual changes insomnia decreased
platelets diabetes osteoporosis kidney
stones and again when you have to give
when when a young person gets estrogen I
mean testosterone they got to get the
rest of their life it's got to be given
by a medical professional you go and I
think it's monthly you get a shot you
have to sit there for half an hour they
have to watch to make sure you're not
going to have untoward side effects Okay
so
yeah
okay estrogen you've got high risk of
prostate and breast cancer high blood
pressure blood clots heart attack uh
stroke depression irritability insomnia
mood swings and diabetes and they came
out with something else recently I just
remembered there was a brain tumor that
from these I don't know if it was the
hormones or the puberty blockers but
there's something new that they come out
with so now they're starting to put
warnings on there's there's brain tumors
yeah and so you know this is what you're
hoping is going to help your child I
mean I guess that
the child is making a decision anyway at
this point but if a parent really does
say okay let's do this it's because
they're hoping that this is going to
help their child and really they're
putting them at so much more risk and we
don't even know long-term side effects
you don't know what your child is going
to uh think later when they're brain
develops and they hit puberty and all
these things like this is just Insanity
that we live in a world like this that
is the word for it really it really is
insane like I said I'm a nurse and I
cannot believe I just I'm just shocked
at what we're doing it's almost like was
it the guy's name mangala the the during
Nazi Germany you did experimenting on
kids thesis this is experimentation yeah
you know this is experimentation and
this should not be this should not be
this person is a male or a female that
transitioned to a male had her uterus
removed you can tell she's probably
early 20s tops and uh this is the type
of stuff that's going on right here yes
hey y'all so I just got my uterus back
and it looks so freaking cool trigger
warning this is an organ and it is a wet
specimen and it is my uterus plus the
tubes as well so ready for the reveal
bye
this is it this is my uterus
she scrubbed off all the blood that is
my cervix that's what a cervix looks
like y'all
and these little strings right here
are my Fallopian tubes this is my uterus
this is it compared to my head
this little thing causes so much
problems for everybody and I also got a
LED plug-in LED stand with it so it
lights up different color and Spins
while it displays it which is so cool
which is so cool I mutilated my body I
can't reproduce
this little thing is what's causing all
the problems she said
it's like but this person's life is
forever altered because of this one
decision that she made at an early age I
mean used to you couldn't have a
vasectomy or your tubes tied at a
certain time in your life right a
certain age or something you don't
remember what the age was but that's
true you know the doctors wouldn't want
to do that because you may change your
mind later yeah and if you listen to
some of this the detransitioners and I
think the rate in the United States of D
transitioners is 30 percent if you
listen to some of the stories and how
they regret you know they you know this
one girl talked about you know how she
was pushed into this and how she regrets
it and how she may never be able to have
a child you know so this is this is just
heartbreaking yeah I mean having your
tubes tied and even vasectomy I think
are reversible you cannot put that back
in your body I mean it's never going to
work again this is forever altering we
have a clip from the documentary what is
a woman and this is just a very powerful
this is going to show you just kind of a
social social media is doing like we
were talking about social media that's a
whole different uh show right there but
social media is really
the New Media that's taken over you know
it's people don't really watch TV Much
Anymore most of the time people are
watching these short format videos on
their phone and this is the type of
stuff they're getting worry that there
there could be a sort of social
contagion element of this
a teeny tiny bit maybe
like looking back on it it was the same
pattern just kids who are really
struggling kids who were very alone and
isolated they have anxiety they don't
fit in with their peers they don't know
where they belong maybe they didn't have
a welcoming Family Life they just got
caught up in these communities online
then they discover hey there's this
group of people and they also don't fit
in they're different they're not sure
who they are gee that's where I fit in
today is the day before my top surgery I
am waking up tomorrow at 5am to have a
subcutaneous mastectomy we're telling
children when they haven't fully
developed that all you have to do is
medically transition and you fit in I
was one of those kids it got me at 42
your child hasn't have a chance
it's all right this is only going in One
Direction you will respect him and I
just don't think it's realistic to put
this decision on them that is basically
saying are you okay with the risk of
permanent
health effects that you can never ever
reverse how can you ask that of such a
small child our hearts break for these
people we're not here to ostracize and
to Mock and like
we're here to love and we're showing
compassion and we're saying that these
people are confused and we don't want
them we want to protect them from making
a decision that's going to alter their
entire life and statistics show leads to
Suicide leads to
more problems medical and everything so
for for us and we they're in the clip
earlier when I was talking about the
medical stuff is saying if you have some
religious
thing against this then you're part of
the problem or whatever
how are we part of the problem when we
want to protect you you know we want to
take more time to think about this
before you make such a huge decision you
know it's interesting in in California
um you know if you I think if you miss
trans if you misgender somebody there's
uh there's I think there's a fine or is
New York or 250 000 fine
um yeah I think it's New York where they
have the 250 000 fine and in California
there might it might be a crime I'm not
sure but but there's I do have some
statistics on what's going on in
California which is very concerning I
did want to mention there was a study
done uh Fox News this was on 115 23 very
recent and this is what U.S more lenient
on transgender treatment than Europe
studies show and it's something called
Do no harm and they said that the
children have greater access in the
United States to gender affirming
medicine uh some states you don't need
any parental permission okay and Dr
Malone he's an endocrinologist and
listen to what he said he said that
doctors are being pressured by the
medical association and politicians for
uh for them to critique and use this
unproven risky medical interventions on
children okay and he said it's the
greatest medical and ethical scandal in
in our time you know and it really is so
doctors are having pressure put on them
to go along with this and you know what
I've lost jobs as a nurse from for
trying to do the right thing and you
know Jesus said if you harm a child in
Matthew 18 6 he said it'd be better for
you to put a thing around your neck a
three thousand pound Stone Millstone and
throw yourself in the ocean so if there
are medical people out there and you
don't feel comfortable with this or you
could be in the psychological profession
or any profession you don't feel
comfortable with this look into this and
have this the guts enough to say no it
may cost you your license but it's worth
it as I had mentioned about Fox News
they had mentioned that in the United
States it's much easier for a child to
transition than in other European
countries in the United States we have
60 pediatric gender clinics plus an
additional 300 clinics that treat a
minors for a gender dysphoria okay in
Europe there's usually one to three in
each in each country UK they close the
Tavistock clinic and I heard a woman
speaking who worked there and she said
they were pressured uh into medically
transitioning these kids and they did
not do adequate mental health
assessments okay they said they're
moving away from the uh gender affirming
approach they're more skeptical now in
the UK I think there was a statistic
that the that the transgender agenda
dysphoria went up four thousand percent
okay
um so they're now discouraging social
transition they use a lot of different
uh instead of just a gender expert they
use pediatricians they bring in
pediatricians they bring in autistic uh
Specialists because a lot of there was a
high percentage that were autistic and
neurologists Etc okay and let's see
Finland okay in 2020 they went away from
what they call wpath which is the gender
affirming Medical Treatments and
organization they now focus on
Psychotherapy and uh let me see to treat
children with gender dysphoria Sweden it
says they use Extreme Caution in gender
affirming medicine unless there is an
exceptional case this is what the board
stated there there is insufficient
evidence on what caused the dramatic
increase in gender dysphoria for teen
girls normally it's young boys that get
this okay so they said and they also
cited the amount of people who are
de-transitioning so they're getting away
France okay France says more caution
needed for treating uh youth due to the
unprecedented increase in transgender
reduce there is a challenge in
identifying gender dysphoria as
permanent or as an adolescent phase and
this is what amazed me nearly all
European countries require parental
consent for transgender surgery when it
comes to children like there's things
happening now in this group that would
never have gone away with
20 years ago like bringing a child into
a bar a 21 and up bar to see a strip
show and and we think this is just
happening in California or something no
we are right here in Tennessee the Bible
Belt and this happened right here in
Chattanooga Tennessee check this out but
there is a a little girl four years old
and now here is a drag queen
it was pasta and throws his legs up to
show up his skirt
and you see that kid is like three years
old less than that
this is in a local bar right here in the
Bible Belt of Chattanooga how is this
happening
how are the cops not involved in this
how's the church not boycotting
protesting outside yes
because now this has become such a
protected Community you know I think
it's ironic that
we get called you know white privilege
and all this stuff but the only group
that I see that's privileged and
protected that gets away with literally
criminal activity like this is this
community
I just can't believe this is happening
hi
I mean this this is not acceptable
no matter what you believe whether
you're a Christian atheist whatever you
don't let little children go into a bar
and see a strip show yes yes and there
was another part of Tennessee I think it
was in Jackson where they they wanted to
do it in a park okay so they get behind
the bar now they want to come out to the
park and the churches got together and I
think one of the the congressmen or
something and they not only did they
prevent it from showing in the park but
they also said if you're going to do it
in the bar you have to be 18 or above
yeah it makes sense so you know when
when people act it stops and I want to
mention something in California it's
very important they passed a bill
recently January 1st I believe it was
it's called SB 107. so California is now
a sanctuary state so if your child says
I want to transgender I want to
transition and you say no well that
child's got to do is get online and and
get and he'll get help to get to
California and once they get to
California this the uh the courts will
take that child out of your jurisdiction
and we'll we'll transition that child
and you have no say in this and this
child isn't even a resident of
California
and the state of California can take
your child from you and start
transitioning exactly and and our
president uh the the the president
Administration they want to put they try
to do this and it failed but they're
going to try again it's Title IX is
sexual discrimination so what they want
to put in there is sexual orientation
and and gender uh identity so again if a
parent says you know I do not want my
child to transgender if this is a
protected you know minority you're not
gonna be able to stop it and there was a
a congresswoman her name was Guzman and
she tried to pass this this law and it
was stopped it kids she said if parents
okay she wants parents to face criminal
charges if they do not affirm their
child's sexual orientation and or gender
identity this was in The Washington Post
10 14 22. okay so you can have a
Christian parent or it could be a Muslim
parent or anybody they don't want their
Childs to transition because of all the
things we say and that this bill would
have passed you would have been thrown
into prison in Canada a man was a man
was
that's insane thrown in prison for
caring about your child who's going to
take these drugs that can lead to heart
attack stroke
uh they'll be the only medical lies for
the rest of their life so that that's 50
60 years they'll they will be
medicalized yeah even if you're a
liberal atheist you would be against
this thing for your child I would think
so and what you know which is what you
said is that you know some parents again
but they're being told by everything in
society if you don't do this your kid
will will commit suicide or they'll hate
you yeah they're being lied to yeah this
was the verse that you said in Matthew
18 6 uh whoever causes one of these
little ones who believe in me to sin it
would be better for him if a millstone
were higher around his neck and he would
drown into the depths of the sea this is
the verse that comes to my mind when you
see these small children being on stage
rubbing on a grown man's crotch in front
of everyone and they're being applauded
this is disgusting this is what's
happening in this world today
people like this girl here who you can
tell has suffered a lot of mental trauma
she you can see that she's been cutting
on herself and she believes that she's a
man and so her mother I'm sure in
desperation to help her daughter has
allowed this to happen allowed to have
her breast chopped off something that's
irreversible and this is do we really
believe that this is going to be the
answer exactly and maybe later on that
she's going to have her uterus removed
you know and um yes so this is this is
terrible and as a nurse is this this
just tears my heart out and I I want to
speak to some resource but I also want
to speak to the fact that according to a
Barnet study 90 of the churches are
silent on this they're silent on this
and you know and it says in Ezekiel 33 I
think it's verses 8 through 10. I'm not
sure but it says if you don't warn a
person who's in a sinful lifestyle of
their ways he said they will die in
their sins okay they will they will be
separated from God throughout attorney
but he says he was speaking to the to
the spiritual leaders of the land he
said I'll hold you accountable their
blood will be on you their blood will be
on your head so I don't know what that
means but I know I don't want that and I
understand that it this is difficult to
stand for this because there's going to
be persecution but the record and maybe
jail time but the ramifications of not
standing for this is going to be much
worse we need to stand so if you're a
pastor out there please stand stand
about this talk about this and I want to
we're going to face the Living God one
day and be held accountable for what we
said and what we didn't say exactly
exactly I want to mention a couple of
resources there's one called um
disconnected dys connected from your
body from your family from reality the
real story behind the transgender
explosion and it's dys
connectedmovies.com you can get a copy
of this it's really very good and it
talks about those who've come out of the
transgender it's beautiful
and this one off this is one of the best
In His Image this is put out by the
American Family Association and it's
also on YouTube I recommend this you get
it from the American the American Family
Association because it's a two-part
video they've only put one part on the
YouTube the second part is the
testimonies and it's powerful and I
really hope that you know churches will
show this uh youth group needs to see
this
um and uh and if you're a parent get a
copy for your and sip with your kids I
think that ones you have restored hope
stored hope they have lots of great
resources great resources for those who
struggle with same-sex attraction and
their families this is called help for
families and again wonderful wonderful
resources the woman Denise schnick I
think her last name is her father was a
transgender she gives her testimony it's
very powerful she's written books for
little kids who are not sure about their
sexual identity she's written some
wonderful books that she's got some
wonderful resources oh praise the Lord
yes
um so we want to talk about some verses
here Isaiah 42 16 says I will bring the
Blind by way they did not know I will
lead them in paths they have not known I
will make Darkness light before them and
crooked places straight these things I
will do for them and not forsake them
this is what the verse that came to me
when you're talking about that Vision
about the path on the right and the path
on the left the path on the right was
worn down and and that you gravitate
towards that because it's easy and
familiar but we can make New Paths our
brains are created in a way where we can
make new habits and with the strength of
God we can do anything he said I'll I'll
give them A New Path you know we there's
one path to God and sometimes we we
stray you know righteous man falls seven
times but God says hey I got a new path
I'm gonna lead you right back and he's
going to keep going after he says I'll
never forsake you amen and I think about
those in the LGBT community is that God
will give you a new path and it will be
a much better path that's right Acts 26
18 says to open their eyes in order to
turn them from Darkness to light and
from the power of Satan to God that they
may receive forgiveness of sins and an
inheritance among those who are
Sanctified by faith in me so our Our
Hope and our the the
precious truth is that God can give us
the power to overcome these things he he
doesn't allow anything to overcome us
that he doesn't have the power to set us
free from he can make a new life for us
and the best part is we get to have
eternal life in a perfect world with no
more pain no more mental issues no more
uh dysphoria
it's just all perfect paradise and who
would want to miss out on something like
that absolutely and even in this life
you know you know some people have today
be concerned about pray the gay away and
you know they say I'm still tempted well
you know what heterosexual homosexual I
don't care who you are there's always
going to be temptation but God pers says
in First Corinthians I think it's 10 13
he says I will provide a way of Escape
amen and I think in second Peter 2 1
where he says he gives us everything we
need for life and godliness we will
always be tempted in all different areas
Jesus was tempted exactly so we will be
tempted but God will provide a way of
escape and God has a much better plan
for our lives amen First Corinthians 6
9-11 says do you not know that the
unrighteous will not inherit the kingdom
of God do not be deceived neither
fornicators nor idolaters nor adulterers
nor homosexuals nor sodomites nor
thieves nor Covetous Norden drunkards
nor revilers nor extortioners will
inherit the kingdom of God and such were
some of you but you were but you were
Sanctified but you were justified in the
name of the Lord Jesus and by the spirit
of our God so we're not we're not
picking on anybody we're not bullying
anybody there's this says drunkers
idolatrous fornicators even even
heterosexual people can fall into the
strap of sexual sin
and and drunkenness and all these things
this is a lifestyle of sin that we're
talking about
when you are converted you will stumble
on occasion but to choose a path of
rebellious and and
um just this lawlessness it leads to
death and destruction and God wants to
set you free from that he says he can
cleanse you of all righteousness he can
he can wash you of that and forgive you
and that's our great hope
Hebrews 4 15-16 says for we do not have
a high priest who cannot sympathize with
our weakness but was in all points
tempted as we as yet as we are yet
without sin Let Us therefore come boldly
to the throne of grace that we may
obtain mercy and find Grace
to help in the time of need
none of us are too far gone that's right
it doesn't matter if you have
transitioned nobody is too far gone for
God
come to him he has mercy and Grace for
all of us and we're
the I know that the church has done
bad the church has done a bad job of
this we've hurt people
but don't judge God by all the
Hypocrites that represent him that's
right God is love God cares about your
life he wants to give you everlasting
life and he wants to transform your life
into something beautiful
so I just thank everybody for being here
if you know anybody that's struggling
with this if you know anybody that's
just raising teens that are in a public
school system or that they're maybe
hanging around the wrong crowd and
they're you know getting exposed to this
kind of thing share this with them
because we want people to to know that
there is hope out there that that this
world of of confusion is is very
impressionable it's causing people to to
take the wrong path and we want parents
to be informed of what's out there so
they know what to look out for what kind
of signs to look for and that this is
not a good choice this there's a lot of
side effects that come health and mental
side effects that come with this and we
just want to tell you that we love you
and that if you have any questions you
can always reach out to us on social
media you can reach out to us on email
you can
just communicate through the the
comments but we love you we would do
anything to to be able to talk to you
and help you through this and most of
all it's Christ Christ gives us the
victory over this but we love you and we
thank you and we'll see you guys next
time on LED live
[Music]
thank you
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you